what's your reaction when you see miles
garrett in his jurassic park tank top
playing basketball
my reaction is uh i think one of those
nba teams should sign him to a 10-day
contract
he's a great athlete uh that doesn't
surprise me seeing him move around i've
he he knows this i've told him this i've
told all of our players listen you got
to stay in shape you need to to do some
things that get your cardio going uh you
got to do it safely and he he's very
very well aware of that but i do marvel
at his athleticism so you didn't do like
the chiefs did a couple of years ago
when we saw the video of pat from homes
playing basketball when they told him no
patrick no more basketball you're fine
with guys doing within reasonable limits
what they need to do to stay in shape i
think that's the key within reasonable
limits they know not to go in some
competitive game where they're going to
turn an ankle or catch an elbow or those
type of things
for example don't do this miles carrot
change of heart from kevin stefanski
after seeing this video over and over
and over again the posterization
i mean that's amazing that guy guarding
him is no joke that's pretty good
defense he gets up there pretty good
i mean we all saw it they saw it in
cleveland and kevin stefanski had this
to say after watching what we're
watching now
and it looks like miles has been working
on his euro step a little bit in the off
season are are you cool with that are
you okay with him playing basketball
he retired
so congratulations yeah great career for
miles really proud of him uh but uh he's
done
did you have to have that talk with him
kevin
he's retired i feel like he's more like
a
a jordan retirement
you know i went to baseball for a second
slash i went to basketball for a second
and i gotta go back to what i'm good at
what i usually do playing football
russian password stop and run
the next season you never know you know
i might go back to basketball i might go
play baseball see if i can get on a team
but like there's more on the horizon
right now i gotta get back to
what my main focus is
i think that last stop was
either a reverse
double pump or a windmill so i had to go
out with the bank
look there's another element to this as
well
it's one thing to see miles garrett
playing basketball during the months
when the offseason exactly exactly up
and running yes when you see this at a
time when players are staying away right
from otas and cleveland is one of the
teams that has experienced that
and we've got a place where you can come
work out in a safe environment and
you're going to go down to planet
fitness and or the y or wherever he was
and play basketball against you know a
couple of jamoks who who would love
nothing more than to test their medal
against miles garrett no no that's how
you get hurt that's not a safe
environment it's too competitive and
you're doing it during a time on the
calendar when we've got all these
state-of-the-art facilities that you can
come get in the right kind of shape for
football season so from end of season
yeah april right or during the six weeks
coming up it's one thing but doing it
when
class is otherwise in session i think
that's the kind of thing that that
catches the attention of a coach yeah i
think so i think you're exactly right i
mean there's just too many what-if
circumstances first off i mean even with
that play right there i mean he's in
traffic he goes up he dunks you land on
somebody's foot sprain your ankle break
your ankle foot whatever i mean it's
it's you know season's over or at least
you're not coming back till late in the
year and i think your point that was
going to be my point you're exactly
right there's a difference in hey i'm
playing basketball late january february
and early march to get in shape but now
hey we're working out we're it's
football season you're a professional
and it's officially the start of
football season here and we have workout
regimens for you and that's where i
think it's it's it's that like what you
brought up and then the last thing too
like yeah you get this far
and
like
it's hey we're we're here
cleveland
you've been crap bola for 20 years
the window is wide open it's super bowl
window time your team is good enough
it's here the hell with basketball so
it's time to play football now and i
think that's probably got to be a little
on stefanski's mind too wait we're
we're in june my team's real i got one
of the best offensive lines in football
one of the best offenses in football the
defense has improved miles garrett was
hurt last year or had the coven and it
hurt our defense and i think all of
those things they just think about it
and go okay that's it it's good for the
year see you next year
here's the other side of it too
if we can cue up the video again of what
we saw last week
it's one thing to go do it it's another
thing to turn it into a social media
moment which is what this clearly was
when you see the cut to the guy with the
headband going
boy
this was concocted this was staged this
was a deliberate job by miles garrett to
create a buzz and a viral moment clearly
don't tape it and don't go out there and
do this saying hey you know i want to
make a great video that people are
really going to like let's go have some
fun so it crosses the line in my mind
from staying in shape to having one of
these and i understand this is the way
the younger generation is look at the
moments this this was a look at me
moment that was concocted that was
deliberate and i think that makes it
even more likely the guy like kevin
stevansky says we don't need this we are
in a super bowl window yeah miles
everyone's impressed by you they all saw
how your biceps were about to rip out of
your jacket when you announced the draft
pick last month we get it you're an
impressive physical specimen you don't
need to make some video of you slamming
the ball through the hoop into some
guy's head to convince people that you
are an impressive physical specialist
that's the real mike i think it's a
great point by you and it also like you
know stop it because you're encouraging
other guys on our team to want to go out
there and do stuff like that so i think
that's where you you kind of try to nip
it in the bud right there and just end
that conversation so i'm glad he's too
damn good he can be the nfl defensive
mvp he's that type of talent you know
and and i don't know in my world of
worlds i guess i look at aaron donald as
probably the best i mean is the best
defensive player in football
miles garrett might be two for me if i
had to really sort it out or something
like that you know and he only got so
many years to play football he's in
shape let's go let's kick some butt
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports